and hemispheric differences are very
striking not only in human beings but
many primates and sort of other other
animals and it's some doubleness has
partly built into you know into the
vertebrate frame so that we have two
kidneys and sort of limbs on each side
where is symmetrical in most ways but
the the two halves of the brain do seem
although obviously they normally they
always work together they do seem or the
different and character and function and
it's very much as if the dominant
hemisphere which is usually the left
hemisphere of the brain is concerned
especially with logical thought and
analysis and sometimes relatively
routine intellectual routines of one
sort and another and the right half of
the brain much more to do with emotion
with novelty with intuition and to some
extent with with identity and one can't
really say that one half is more
important than the other because they
they have to come together completely